If there's one thing you do today.
Just one thing.
One thing.
Get your local business online.
Get online.
15 million businesses do not have a website.
That's 58 percent of all US businesses.
The more businesses we get online, the more jobs we create.
What if every business could hire just one person?
That's a lot of new jobs.
I went from 1 employee to 24.
The Web took us from a local shop to a global business.
Over 50 percent of our students come from the Web.
You can help in a big way.
In a big way.
You might own a business,...
...or know a friend or family member who does.
If there's one thing you do today...
Tell your mother,...
...your brother,...
...a sister,...
...your cousin,...
...your uncle,...
...a friend...
...or amigo,...
...your ex,...
...there's just one thing.
One thing.
Let's support our local community.
LC's Bar-B-Q.
The Book Rack.
Touch Vinyl.
The Jungle.
Icon Architecture.
The Gown Gallery.
Caraballo Locksmith.
El Diablo Moto Shop.
Let's jumpstart America.
If there's one thing you do today.
Just one thing.
Get a business online.